je rappelle la question orale numéro
1624 de monsieur alain fouché à monsieur
mise de l'intérieur
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
concerne l'avenir de la politique en
matière de contrôle de vitesse sur les
routes françaises depuis longtemps je
lutte avec nombre de mes collègues tous
horizons pour que cesse cette politique
du chiffre instaurée il ya plusieurs
années par la mise en place de radars
automatiques est aujourd'hui amplifiée
sans concertation à la demande de votre
prédécesseur par le retrait des panneaux
les annonçant à l'heure où la grande
majorité des pays européens américains
procèdent à leur démontage le seul pays
au monde où ils sont en constante
augmentation c'est la france on peut se
poser nombre de questions qualité du
réseau routier
insuffisance du nombre de forces de
l'ordre besoin de rentrées d'argent
certes nous constatons depuis
l'apparition des premiers radars
automatiques en 2002 une diminution
moyenne de la vitesse de 10 km heure
mais les premières causes de mortalité
sur nos routes sont bien la vitesse
excessive la drogue et l'alcool nous
sommes tous partisans de sanctionner
plus sévèrement ce genre de comportement
mais il faut cesser ce matraquage
agressif à l'égard des auteurs de
petites infractions léger excès de
vitesse car il pénalise toujours les
plus vulnérables et les moins aisés qui
ne peuvent procéder au rachat de points
comme le font illégalement les plus
riches
j'ai fait voter il ya quelques mois des
mesures permettant de récupérer ses
points plus rapidement c'est une avancée
pour les travailleurs qui à la suite
d'une perte de points ont le choix entre
perdre leur emploi ou continuer de
conduire mais sans permis plus de 450
milles sont dans ce dernier cas en 2011
selon les sources de votre ministère
j'attire également monsieur le ministre
votre attention sur les obstacles
administratifs afférents à la
contestation d'une contravention car
c'est un vrai parcours du combattant en
cas de contestation l'administration se
contente de faire parvenir aux
contrevenants
la majoration de l'amande par lettre
recommandée si celui ci ne peut prouver
qu'il n'était pas au volant et c'est
souvent le cas l'amendé peut s'élever
plus de 500 euros le citoyen monsieur
minuit ce doit pouvoir être entendue et
pouvoir se défendre monsieur le ministre
ce n'est pas votre ministère qui a mis
en place cette politique mais je
souhaiterais savoir quelle décision
le gouvernement prendra sur ces deux
points les petits excès de vitesse pas
accidentogène et la possibilité de
contester ce sont des points qui
préoccupent un grand nombre de nos
concitoyens
merci de votre réponse
merci mon cher collègue la parole était
monsieur manuel valls ministre de
l'intérieur
c'est le sénateur alain fouché sur eux
de vous retrouver ici de pouvoir vous
répondre je crains cependant de ne pas
aller tout à fait dans votre sens vous
avez rappelé la baisse régulière de la
mortalité sur les routes françaises
depuis 1971 et je veux souligner les
bons résultats en terme de sécurité
routière la politique du contrôle
automatisé mis en place notamment à
partir de 2002 sous l'impulsion du
président chirac a donné des résultats
très nette très vite dès l'année 2003 le
parc de radars automatiques en france
est constituée aujourd'hui de 3800
équipements avec un objectif de fin
d'année situé régulièrement légèrement
pardon en dessous de 4100 là où la
grande bretagne je crois en compte plus
de 7000 le maillage territorial de ses
équipements me semble à ce stade être
proche de ce que l'on peut réaliser un
objectif optimum ainsi à compter de
l'année 2013 le volume global du parc
sera maintenue au taux de 4200
équipements en assurant à la fois le
renouvellement des systèmes les plus
anciens et l'adaptation continue du parc
aux enjeux de sécurité routière par
ailleurs concernant vos interrogations
relatives aux sanctions des petits excès
de vitesse
sujet que nous connaissons et
comme élus locaux nous sommes souvent
rappelé à cette question je tiens à vous
rappeler qu'il n'ya malheureusement pas
de mon point de vue de petites
infractions sur les routes lorsque des
vies sont en jeu mais je veux se dire de
manière très nette que tout allègement
des sanctions
entraînerait nécessairement une
augmentation de la vitesse moyenne sur
nos routes et a fortiori de
l'accidentalité et de la mortalité
n'oublions pas qu'une relation
scientifiquement établie existe entre la
vitesse et la gravité des accidents 1%
de vitesse en plus c'est 4 % de morts en
plus pour cette raison il ne me semble
pas raisonnable de modifier les
sanctions prévues pour ces infractions
enfin vous attirer mon attention sur les
difficultés que rencontrerait nos
concitoyens pour contester une
infraction c'est peut-être le cas
n'hésitez pas à m'en parler je crois
cependant que les possibilités offertes
à chacun sont précises et sont
clairement présenté dans l'avis de
contravention si le véhicule a été de
prêter volés ou détruits il suffit sans
consignation de désigner le conducteur
ou d'envoyer les justificatifs ad-hoc
pour que les poursuites soient arrêtés
les autres cas de contestation demande
la consignation du montant de l'amendé
pour être prises en compte pour mémoire
dans le cas des dépassements de moins de
20 km/heure constaté hors agglomération
le montant a consigné et de 68 euros
après délibération du tribunal de
proximité compétents si la contestation
reçoit gain de cause le montant est
systématiquement reversés à l'intéressé
j'entends évidemment certains de vos
arguments monsieur le sénateur et
monsieur péchenard vos délégué es prêt
j'imagine à rencontrer et à travailler
avec les élus sur ces questions c'est
évidemment également l'invitation que je
vous fais mais je crois que si nous
relâchions un tant soit peu l'effort
nous enverrions un très mauvais signal
les cas que vous évoquez non évidemment
sont pas directement liées aux incidents
les accidents dramatiques de ces
dernières heures mais tout de même c'est
à dire sur place dans le 19e
arrondissement de paris
et j'ai pu malheureusement constater ce
que un chauffard mais voleur a plié sous
l'emprise de l'alcool du cannabis peut
être amené à faire mais c'est pour ça
que le message général doit être pesé et
en la matière la fermeté est une
nécessité le nombre de morts sur les
routes a baissé car la sécurité routière
est devenue une priorité et dans mon
ministère cette priorité doit demeurer
si monsieur le ministre parle que
monsieur alain fouché monsieur le
ministre flamand de documents sur les
petits excès de vitesse c'est là dessus
que je reviens sur les chauffards tout
le monde est d'accord mais ce sont les
plus petits qui en font toujours les
frais et les français on a l'impression
d'un vrai matraquage fiscal
sur la contestation il ya du flou je
suis prêt à me rapprocher du délégué
vous indiquez le nom mais les choses ne
passent pas très bien d'une manière
générale les gens peuvent pas contesté
très bien et il arrive à payer des
amendes très forte demande tribunal donc
je crois qu'il a besoin de te regarder
de près les faits cette ouverture vous
en remercie et je me rapprocherai de
votre ministère et du délégué